the eu's approach to fighting terrorism
took center stage at the first general
affairs council of the year following
january's events in paris
ministers underlined the importance of
seeking agreement on travel surveillance
in order to monitor movements of terror
suspects
latvian foreign minister ed garinkovics
told reporters after the meeting
we had a very broad discussion during
today's general affairs council on
terrorism and
all the necessary measures the european
union
must take and i have to say that there
have been a very broad agreement
in the general affairs council during
our discussion that we have to move
forward with passenger names register we
also had a very broad agreement
concerning
um let's say the need to address
terrorism in the
comprehensive
way
the council also approved an agreement
on new rules to prevent money laundering
and terrorist financing
ministers also discussed a revision of
the multi-annual financial framework
the aim is to allow the eu to transfer
21.1 billion euros of unused funds from
2014 for use over the next years
as chairman of the meeting rinkovics
expressed optimism that agreement
allowing member states to use the
investment funds as agreed in the mff
regulation could soon be reached
ministers cast an eye over march's eu
leaders meeting agenda which will focus
on energy union relations with ukraine
and russia and economic issues